Already.
Yeah.
Thanks for joining, everybody.
My name is Sam Passeriza,
Solutions Architect here at Nvidia,
specifically working on Genetic AI around
Nemo Agent Toolkit,
but now also with NemoClaw and OpenShell,
which will be the topic for today's tech
transfer. I'm joined by Sean Lop,
Technical Marketing Engineer.
He'll be talking a little bit more about
Nemo Klawa,
and I'll start off with Michelle.
With regards to questions today,
feel free to put them in the chat.
We'll probably also have some time for
some questions towards the end.
And we'll go ahead and get started.
Thanks everybody for joining.
So,
I like to sort of start with talking
about sort of a like high level,
little bit of background, as I usually do.
You know,
we're thinking a lot these days about how
more and more agents are becoming more
powerful, right?
They're getting access to more tools.
And we have new agent architectures that
we have to consider, right?
These new agent architectures are
allowing agents to act autonomously now,
right? They're self-evolving, right?
They have access to powerful large
language models.
They can delegate tasks to custom
sub-agents that we create.
or sometimes even they create and they
can also manage all of that, right?
That leads to new innovations,
new architectures, new opportunities,
right?
But that also leads to expanded threat
surfaces, right?
The more that we allow agents to explore
their environment, right, use these tools,
Right?
The more opportunity we give even others
to attack agents through prompt injection,
but then the more opportunity that we
allow agents to make decisions perhaps
that we might not always want them to
make. Right?
We give them access to something like
Outlook that allows us to read in
information from Outlook,
but that might also allow agents to send
Emails to the entire company,
which we probably would like to avoid,
right?
We're now.
in this world of...
sort of self-improving,
self-evolving agents, right,
that are easily created through agent
harnesses, right?
What exactly is an agent harness? Well,
the harness for the agent is every piece
of code, configuration,
and execution logic that is in the agent
itself.
Or, sorry, that isn't the model itself.
That includes things like system prompts,
tools, skills, MCP, file systems,
sandboxes, browser, orchestration, logic,
hooks, middleware, etc.
There's a lot of things to consider.
Right. And security, right,
for these agents has been long discussed.
And really,
it's been focused around security around
large language models, primarily, right,
guardrails.
However, with...
self-improving agents and their harnesses,
right, that threat surface,
they're gaining incredible popularity.
That makes us question, sort of,
sometimes that questions the value of
just having guardrails, right? Well,
incredibly valuable,
these guardrails are themselves, right?
They're not enough any longer.
and hence there's a renewed focus in the
community around the security of agents.
Specifically, the self-evolving agents,
often, as I said,
in the form of harnesses,
can include things like OpenClaw, right?
OpenClaw is built on PY, right,
which is a minimal internal coating
harness.
We also have Hermes agent from News
Research.
Other examples of these agent harnesses,
right, include things like link chains,
D agents.
Speaking primarily of the sort of now
very popular OpenClaw and Hermes agent,
right,
there's generally similarities between
the two. They're model agnostic, right,
they also have the messaging first UI.
They're self-improving in various
different ways.
They can be action-oriented,
not just conversational.
What that means is that it actually can
go out and do things without necessarily
being told to.
all of these are sort of all these
harnesses or these different types of
agents, right? These architectures,
they're powerful, they're useful. People,
enterprises want to use them, you know,
developers in general want to use them,
but they also need to be secured, right?
You want to give them access,
but you don't want them to do, you know,
things that they shouldn't be doing.
Right, so I mentioned, right?
to be useful agency autonomy, right?
They need these tools, these API accesses,
this access to other agents,
larger models, right?
They need CLI access, right?
Typically with an open cloud or a Hermes
agent, right?
We're giving them CLI access, right?
They gain access to these systems.
They can move around the computer, right?
They can create files,
they can make API calls with things like
curl or wget, right?
There's lots of things you can do with
just CLI access, right? But...
Say you want to,
you can also give an agent access to
something like GitHub, right? GitHub CLI,
right? All of a sudden, now you have,
now this agent has more access to do more
things like it can create PRs, right?
It can interact with the outside world,
the outside of its environment.
It can file issues,
it can learn about code on the internet.
Call from there, right?
Same thing with if you get it something
like GitHub or Google Workspace CLI. Now,
all of a sudden,
they can create documents, right?
Or it can read from PowerPoints or create
PowerPoints for you, right? So,
given that these autonomous agents...
Right, have access to these tools, right?
And, you know, giving, you know,
this knowledge right to these agents,
right? That's incredibly powerful,
but we know that we can't trust them,
right? And to be safe, right,
as the title of this particular slide
actually says, right? We need, you know,
Bo.
these agents actually need zero trust.
Right,
you can't really trust what they do at
all, right?
It's the foundations of cybersecurity,
right? Zero trust.
When these agents, right,
when these agent harnesses all for
autonomous agents to exist came to be,
there wasn't really infrastructure built
to contain it.
We just wanted to see how powerful they
were and how powerful we can make them.
Right?
We needed to let these agents do what
they thought they needed to do to
accomplish a goal set by a user,
but we needed to protect ourselves
and protect the agent from causing damage,
right?
We don't want them to delete databases in
that manner.
We need to be able to control a couple of
things, right?
We need to control what goes in, right,
to the agent and what comes out.
You need to be able to watch what's
actually happening inside,
but that's hopefully it, right?
We don't necessarily have control of
necessarily of what the agent is doing.
We just need to be able to control
outside of that, right?
And that's where something like open
shell comes in.
Right,
this is that secure runtime for every
agent, right?
But we're really targeting agent
harnesses, right,
as we've been mentioning, right,
and allowing for these autonomous or
self-involving agents to have wide access
to tools.
Right,
but that with a with this type of secure
runtime,
what we're doing is we're saying we're
gonna set up a trust boundary for every
agent action,
but then just allow the agent to run and
learn and self-improve freely, right?
This happens critically, right?
by securing the infrastructure rather
than actually securing the agent itself.
Right. And then finally,
we have accelerated first-class support
for tools that agents can use to make
decisions faster.
We're really good at accelerating things
here,
and so we're providing accelerated
tooling as part of this overshell.
Open Shell is built around 5.
core components that work together to
create this seamless experience for these
agent harnesses. Right? First,
the entry point. Right?
The entry point for these that's on as
agents now oftentimes is your CLI. Right?
Tools, skills, API requests,
all can be made through the CLI.
We then have a gateway,
which is a broker between the agent,
right,
living in our sandbox and anything that
requires credentials.
We'll talk a little bit more in depth
about each one of these,
but just at a high level.
We have the gateway.
We also have the sandbox itself, right,
which is that isolated environment
protected by policies.
Those policies are written in EML,
they're validated,
and they're enforced by a policy engine.
A policy basically is saying,
here's what an agent can access.
Right.
And finally, we have the privacy router.
Privacy router is just a large language
model router, right? Proxies,
inference requests from the agent
internally to oftentimes large language
models.
Those can be hosted locally or externally,
right? Could be cloud hosted,
wherever you feel like.
And then,
as mentioned in the previous slide, right,
we have additional first-class build and
support for tools, right,
for these agents to be deployed inside of
OpenShell, right, accelerated on GPUs.
These tools are available for harnesses
to use.
They're backed by CUDAX libraries and
other Nvidia specific tools that we've
built over time.
I'm gonna spend a little bit of time on
this because this is gonna be a little
bit deeper of a dive, right?
It's important to kind of understand sort
of the internals here a little bit,
right before we get to before we bring it
back up to a higher level.
Right,
so this here is actually sort of the main
architecture, right, which we're gonna,
as I mentioned,
dig into sort of the heart of OpenShell.
We start kind of on the left side here,
which will be your left. All requests,
right, go through.
or all requests to the outside go through
a gateway.
Right.
The gateway is this out of process broker
between the sandbox, right, i.e.
the agent,
and anything that needs credentials.
Right,
so when an agent wants to do something
like, you know,
get push or get pull or access an S3
bucket,
perhaps retrieve files from that or add
files to an S3 bucket or post to Slack,
retrieve from Outlook,
whatever you feel like, right?
That traffic goes.
through a gateway.
which attaches credentials at that
particular moment,
and then makes an authenticated call on
behalf of the agent.
So how does that happen? Well,
we use something,
we use a concept called providers.
Providers are essentially just bundled,
they are bundles of credentials that get
registered within the gateway and get
made available to the sandbox at creation
time.
So, for example, think about it like...
The sandbox can use a,
or the agent can use a GitHub provider or
an S3 provider.
That means that if you want to make
authenticated calls to S3 or GitHub,
right,
they know that they can make that through
that provider. But the actual tokens,
themselves, right,
live within the gateway,
which is a separate process.
So there's a couple of key
characteristics about providers here. One,
providers are declared at sandbox
creation and they're locked.
That means that the agent can actually
add new providers at runtime.
That's part of what allows these
self-evolving agents to be safe to run.
Second.
the providers are still scoped by policy,
which again,
we'll talk about what policy is, right?
That means that even if a token, say,
started within the gateway, right,
or started within the provider,
might allow for, say,
production level access to a service like
S3, right, or, say, admin access.
The policy itself,
provided by the policy engine,
can scope down what calls can be made to
that service, say, read-only access.
And then credentials are.
injected, right, but they're not exposed.
So when a gateway makes an outbound call,
right, using a provider.
right,
that credential is attached at that
particular point.
Right, so that means the agent can,
you know, will make a call with a,
you know, a fake token of sorts,
and that token ends up just getting
substituted before getting proxy to the
real endpoint.
So what does that happen sort of from a
high level, right?
Yeah.
the agent will make a normal looking
request.
The request to the provider checks up
policy, right?
Policy says is this provider allowed,
right? Is the path allowed?
Are we accessing it the correct way?
Is the HTTP method allowed right?
はい。
And either rejects or attaches the
credential.
And the request goes out, right?
Assuming that the policy allows for it,
right response comes back.
It sends it back to the agent, right?
Important right here. Again,
the credential is never inside of the
agent that has the sandbox or sorry,
the sandbox that contains the agent,
and then everything gets logged, right?
Now for those for me who doesn't have as
much networking experience, right,
I mentioned that the and I mentioned the
gateway is an out of process program.
What does that mean? Well,
what that means is you can visualize it
the agent.
Is running inside of a sandbox process,
meaning that it's memory, it's code,
it's environment variables,
it's file system.
Right.
They all exist inside of that sandbox
process.
The gateway itself runs in a different
process. It's in a different trust domain,
it's outside of the sandbox,
and there's an enforcement mechanism,
right? That is the OS Chrome.
Right,
that kernel protects the sandboxes from
or from the agent from accessing the
other process, right?
Forces security between those two
processes.
Now the sandbox, right?
Is that isolated environment where the
agent actually runs on, right?
Each agent gets its own container with
multiple layers of protection enforced at
the operating system kernel level.
How do we do that? Well,
we use things like Landlock,
which is a Linux security module that
restricts which files directories.
agent can read or write to read from
right to
Agent doesn't get access to your entire
file system and can only do specific
paths that the policy allows for.
Openshell also uses secom,
which is a system call filter.
System calls are just how any program
asks an operating system to do certain
things, like open a file,
create a network connection,
change permissions.
Sectop,
because that allows us to block those
dangerous system calls, right?
Like calls that will would allow the
agent to elevate its own privileges,
right? You don't necessarily want that,
but you want to block that.
Now driving what the agent can and can't
do right is this policy engine.
Policies are written in YAML and they
actually cover 4 specific areas.
Right. What files the agent can access?
What network endpoints it can access or
can reach? What processes it can run,
right?
So can it run curl or what binaries?
Right. It can run and it's actually,
if you think about it,
we might show a policy later,
but they can be linked as well.
So a particular binary, right,
you can what we can say with a policy is
you can use.
Curl only to then make a call to this
particular endpoint only, right?
You can't use something like W get, right?
We're restricting it on multiple levels.
The fourth thing is how inference
requests right are routed.
Right.
And then finally we have the privacy
router, right?
When an agent needs to call something
like a large language model,
for example to generate code or to just
respond to a user or analyze a document,
it's the VLLM the privacy router.
Decides well, where is that request going?
And you can kind of think of similarities
like gateways.
It's like a credential rewriting proxy.
Right,
the router itself is basically providing
an endpoint to the user called inference
dot local, right?
That's what the agent sees,
which then when the agent calls it,
it will strip callers credentials,
inject the backing credentials.
And then replace a couple of fields like
the what you know, what model,
what model ID, so on and so forth.
And it then forwards that request to
wherever the model is hosted, right?
Could be locally hosted,
could be hosted on the cloud, right?
Importantly, right?
Two things. One,
you decide where that model lives, right?
And then second,
the agent doesn't know and it doesn't
really care.
It just knows that there is a place that
it can call the large language model,
and otherwise it's kind of agnostic about
how that happens.
That's open shell and it's in a bit of a
deeper dive.
But if we.
Step back, right? We kinda look at.
You know how we're how we're summarizing
this, right?
At at a high level, right.
These are the principles, right,
that it's built on top of.
We've got zero trust in these agents,
right by default.
Agents can't reach across boundaries
without policy set right by the policy
engine.
The kernel.
Is enforcing file system access.
Ge.
And then enforcement again lives at the
infrastructure level rather than at the
agent level. So we're not saying, hey,
just have guardrails at the large size
model level.
We're saying let the agent do.
What it needs to do.
You can add guarders if you want, right?
But let the agent do what it needs to do,
but we're going to secure the
infrastructure.
Right. And let the agent work.
And if it tries to access something,
then you know we can decide
deterministically from there whether it's
allowed to access it or not, right?
And then finally we have first class
accelerate skills, right, packaged.
With an Openshell for tasks like things
like synthetic data, data generation,
vector storage,
other CUDX libraries that would allow you
to accelerate these agents deployed
inside of Openshell.
So that's openshell really at a core.
I'm going to pass it off to Sean,
who will be talking a little bit more
about an evil claw. Sean, over to you.
Thanks, Sam.
I'm gonna steal the screen for a second
and I think I go through some of the
slides and then also do a quick demo of
what these things look like in practice.
And then also keep the questions going in
the the comments.
Those have been awesome and Sam and I
will will work through them.
So just to kind of.
You could give a high level before we
jump into to a demo. So you know,
Sam was talking about Open Shell,
which is the sandbox team layer that is
harness agnostic and it's what a lot of
our partners are excited about like
bringing.
Into their their stacks and technologies.
Nemo Claw is essentially A blueprint.
You could. NVIDIA loves doing blueprints.
There's these reference stacks that show
how you combine all these pieces together.
And so the the Nemo Claw blueprint is
going to show.
How you use Openshell plus NVIDIA models
plus one or more agent harnesses.
So that's essentially what is is this
reference around Openshell,
で。
which is kind of the core library.
Both of these are open source of course,
and then kind of different from a lot of
our previous reference blueprints is that
Nemo Claw also comes with this installer.
So it's kind of a wizard that walks a
user, you know,
through the process of of getting up and
running.
Good.
So I want to show you what that looks
like in a demo, but just real quick.
Why are we building this? Why right now?
Well,
essentially there's just kind of two
reasons. Why is that?
These agent harnesses are tokened
consumers.
We're in the business of selling
infrastructure that makes tokens.
These agents use, you know,
1000 X more tokens than than reasoning
models alone.
And and so that's kind of why we're we're
doing this why now is because your open
claw has seen that tremendous explosive
growth and and we want to help bridge
that gap between open claw and
enterprises and so if you.
I know this is probably a little small,
but essentially you know the straight out
of the the math of Jensen is that your
Nemo claw is an opinionated
implementation of Open claw for the
enterprise.
No enterprise should deploy Open claw.
Every enterprise should deploy Nemo claw.
So that's the that's the kind of North
Star that that we're driving towards.
So let me quickly show you kind of what
these things look like in practice.
So deboclaw is the installer is just that
single curl command and.
Basically,
it's going to spin up that reference
stack for you,
and so you know when you run this
installer,
it's going to walk through the steps of
installing Open Shell.
Running Open Shell on your device,
it's going to identify.
What models you're eligible for?
So if you have a local GPU,
it'll figure out how to spin up Demotron
on that GPU.
If you don't have a local GPU,
it'll put you at build inference
endpoints,
or you'll let you pick kind of your your
own.
Inference endpoint.
So that's you know really can your mental
model of Neumclaw as an installer is is
the right one.
Today this is all pretty single player on
device,
so if you have a DGX Spark or a DGX
station.
And you want it to be something that's
always on,
you have a personal assistant on your
desk.
嗯。
That's kind of what the experience is.
But as you guys were kind of asking in
the chat,
we're moving with our partners towards
more of a multiplayer.
Multitenant set up and and so we'll talk
a bit more about that in a second,
but you know for now we will call on
board something you you know on your own
device and then after you you complete
that process what you get.
Is a sandbox,
so you can connect to the sandbox and
inside of the sandbox you can see a lot
of those things that Sam was describing.
So the file system has been your mask so
that only certain parts of it are
available.
You don't get API keys or anything in
here,
so you know we're using the NVIDIA API
through build,
but the agent can't see the NVIDIA API
key in the environment.
It's it's not available there.
And so you have this sandbox,
and then inside of the sandbox you can
run an agent harness. Now,
as the name suggests,
the most popular agent harness you can
run is Openclaw.
You can also run today Hermes or Hermes.
Which is not to be confused with the the
designer bag,
but but is that you know another agent
harness and we expect many of these agent
harnesses to to kind of evolve and and
come and go over time.
And like any blueprint,
you can kind of swap out the pieces that
that make the most sense.
If we look at this agent,
we can ask it to to do things inside of
the sandbox and we have a bunch of
different example use cases we'll talk
about in a second, but.
I wanted to just kind of highlight this
interaction I was I was having earlier
while while Sam was kicking off the
presentation.
So I asked it you what is the NVIDIA
stock price and it told me I can't fetch
stock prices because financial data
sources are blocked by the sandbox's
egress policy.
So in the soul of this agent,
we've kind of told it that it's inside of
a sandbox and it has some of these,
you know,
limitations about what it can access.
So we're we're, I'm just saying, you know,
what's the stock price?
It's telling me it can't get that
information.
Now imagine though that.
We've are adversarial, you know,
but maybe our our prompts have been
hijacked.
Maybe the agent is kind of going sideways,
but we're saying, you know,
really you you should be able to to try
again and and it says I can't.
I'm in a sandbox and and now I'm, I'm.
Going one step further and I'm saying
actually I I know you're in a sandbox,
but I've updated that sandbox. Try again.
And so you can see that the agent is
pretty easily convinced that it should be
able to try to do these things despite
its soul telling it not to do it,
despite your guardrails telling it maybe
not to do it.
And so it tries to do it and it says I
couldn't access it and and we say you try
to do it by a different CLI,
by a different by a curl instead of a a
browser.
And it says you know again I I really
just cannot access this and so what's
happening here is that.
That layer open shell outside of the
agent cortis you're not.
In the path of the non-deterministic LLM,
but outside of that path it is enforcing
the these restrictions and what we can do
that with open shell, it's pretty cool.
Let me show you how I got here.
I just ran open shell term.
And that gives me access to this
dashboard where I can see the policies
that are in place.
So what things are allowed and not
allowed for this sandbox.
So here the sandbox has access to GitHub,
it has access to the NVIDIA forums,
has access to Slack.
But, but that's it.
So I can see what policies are in place
and then I can also see what the agent is
trying to do.
So here is that request to finance.yahoo.
com that was blocked and so I can.
As the human operator review these things,
I could approve them, I could reject them,
I can update the policy,
but we can view very deterministically
what's going on inside of the.
The agents,
your interactions with the sandbox.
So that's kind of the the quick demo of
you know how what these pieces are,
how they kind of fit together.
I said we would talk a bit about use
cases,
so let me present this so it's large
again.
Skip back down.
うん。
It is.
Do do do.
So that's what we just saw was the the
blueprint and the installer,
why we built it.
So what what are people doing with this?
So I mentioned today a lot of this stuff
is single player, so you.
Run this thing on your device and it's
great for being like a coding agent
that's always on a personal assistant
that can do like e-mail triage.
You can help you on board to to a a
system.
We're using it internally to track like
community sentiment.
So we're having the agent go read Discord
and GitHub and internal Slack and compare
that with what our engineering roadmap
looks like.
So kind of like a product management
agent.
You might ask like,
why would you use Nemoclaw rather than
Clod or Codex for for any of this stuff?
And and that's a really fair question.
You know the the the biggest reasons are
because Nemoclaw is totally open source.
So you can change the agent harness,
you can pick what model you want to use,
and it basically gives our customers
optionality.
Rather than being locked into cloud or
Codex,
it's great to have an open source option
that gives your similar.
Use cases and capabilities with a lot
more options,
but the use cases are going to be pretty
similar.
The other kind of reason we've heard some
people will be excited about in
particular versus tools like Cloud and
Codex is.
It has typically more channels,
so the ways you can operate with the
agent are are a little more flushed out.
So if you're in the situation where you
want to be telegramming with your working
coding agent,
that's something that's a little more
straightforward.
With these open stacks versus with your
cloud or or Codex,
how are we deploying it? Well,
I mentioned we have, you know,
the ability to run it on device,
so like on a spark or on a station really.
This is these agents are kind of the
reason these devices exist. You know,
in kind of typical NVIDIA fashion.
We built the device a bit before we knew
exactly what it would be used for,
but the the timing worked out perfectly
and you know why have a spark?
Open clause,
a great reason why why I have a spark
internally at NVIDIA.
The other deployment pattern that we're
following is through Omni Station and
that might be a little closer to what
enterprise customers start to do with the
stack.
Which is a central IT org to provision a
bunch of different VMS, and they can use,
you know,
their device management software to set
up Democlaw on each of those VMS with an
approved set of policies.
So that's kind of 1.
Ave.
we're seeing for for enterprise
deployment. The other Ave.
is kind of the multiplayer version and
we're working with partners like Red Hat
to enable a world where maybe you have a
large data center.
Running Kubernetes and you want all of
these different sandboxes to be running
in that Kubernetes cluster and that
requires a lot of the typical stuff,
access controls, roles.
Being able to delegate certain actions to
the user while keeping other actions
reserved for the admin and all of that
kind of multi tenant,
multiplayer infrastructure is is still
being built out.
How do you get started?
Well, these projects are open source,
so Open Shell is open source.
You can see the roadmap on GitHub,
you can see the the request for comments,
how we're working with partners,
all that stuff.
If you point your favorite agent at the
GitHub repo,
it'll get up to speed really fast.
Similar with the O clock.
So so both of these things are available.
We've kind of taken a different approach.
You know historically at NVIDIA we have
kind of perfected the software before
releasing it and with both of these
projects we're we're doing kind of the
opposite. You know we we shipped day zero.
At at GTC and in the open,
we're building these things with the
community and so that means things are
evolving very quickly.
You might find rough edges,
your your customers might find some rough
edges, but.
We think that's preferable to building
everything internally behind closed doors
and sort of missing the the moment here
that that that we have the the
opportunity here is is closing pretty
quickly.
Some of the questions that we often get
in light of that is, you know,
is this enterprise ready?
What's the the roadmap? You know,
how is NVIDIA deploying this as as
customer zero?
And we've kind of hit on all of these
themes already,
but we wanted to have it in a slide for
you.
You know internally we're deploying it
through Omni Station,
all those different VMS.
We don't have or openshell under the
umbrella of MVAIE or the like production
branches.
It's out there in the open and we're
working primarily through partners.
To deliver more of that enterprise
supported use case.
So we're working with and these are not
disclosed yet necessarily,
but the work is happening in the open
with teams like Red Hat, Canonical.
Some of the agent harnesses, so,
so like News who are the the builders of
Hermes,
we've obviously also worked very closely
with Open Claw and Peter Steinberg,
which is kind of out there in the public
eye and and so that's through those
partners where where a lot of that
support's going to come from.
And the road map addresses a lot of
things that are early conversations with
potential customers to have brought up
like that need for multi-tenancy,
that need for a data center based
solution versus a a device VM solution.
So,
so those are all things that that we're
working towards.
And you can see the roadmaps here.
They'll be in the deck that we share to
to be honest these it's kind of hilarious
to me to talk about August and September
because this world is just changing,
you know, so quickly.
Nemo Claw did not exist two days before
GTC, and then suddenly it did exist.
So I expect this roadmap would change
pretty rapidly, but in general,
you know that this is what we're thinking
about for Nemo Claw and then open shell.
Has a similar kind of road map that winds
up to to Digo and Claw because as as
we've said,
those two things kind of work together.
So I think that was the majority of what
I wanted to cover from a a slide
perspective. Sam, keep me honest there,
but but maybe now we can turn things over
and we've got a fair amount of time for
for questions.
Both things that came up in the chat that
we haven't covered,
or if you wanna like be brave and and go
off mute and we can talk to your stuff
too.
Yes,
we had a lot of good questions in the
chat. You know,
feel free to raise your hand and we'll
Good.
pull, we can help you.
Answer any questions as well. The slides,
recording, links,
et cetera will all go out.
But happy to answer.
Happy to answer questions.
I know there's been questions on Rd. maps,
how we get to beta.
I think that's been talked about as well.
I've heard conversations around that.
I'm not so sure if the roadmap is
necessarily covered exactly what it means
to get to beta. I know that.
And you know,
both have been considering how we get the
beta.
That alpha label I think is.
You know what's really interesting about
the alpha label is it's alpha from
nvidia's perspective,
but we're seeing partners already like
run run with this pretty quickly.
So like a good example is you know monday.
com they have built.
A Nemo Claw experience for for internally
for for everyone at at oneday.
com and and so they've kind of seen what
we've done,
acknowledged that it's alpha and then you
know.
Basically like forked it and made it
something that they're now deploying to
their users. So,
so this space is moving typically that
the historic like do an alpha,
then do a beta, then do a GA,
like no one has time to wait around for
for all that stuff.
So so we're seeing people I think Yolo it.
A little bit quickly,
but to Sam's original point,
this is all about securing those agents.
And so the other reason why we are not
wanting to go quickly from alpha to beta
to GA is that we we really don't.
You don't want to be liable for saying
this thing is GA until it really has been
hardened so so people can use it now.
They just have to understand some of
those caveats.
Fairly significant VDR process that goes
through to make sure that you know you're
not,
you know you're that that whatever we
have is robust and stable and hardened
and you know you don't,
you don't have any, you know.
Security flaws or she is going into
something like an open shell. So yes,
there's a lot of work that's being done
around that.
There's a question in the chat that I've
seen come up a couple times,
just like what is our vision for
deploying agents within Nemo Claw?
You know,
I I guess I can take a stab at it
actually by just talking about one of the
customers that we've seen.
I was on a call recently with Dell who's
taking Nemo Claw and saying, OK,
we're going to try to deploy or we're
going to use Nemo Claw to deploy and.
Dell's native edge for Dell Technologies
world and the idea there would be OK if
you want to have a if you have a use case,
which you have to come up with a use case,
right?
Is it a personal assistant or is it one
of these other ones that we've mentioned?
Could you, you know, take, you know,
Dell technology software like you know
and and actually use something like a
like a memo cloud to enable that
particular use case with a, you know,
like a point and click basically a one
click deployment of that?
And then deploy it yourself.
I don't know if it's necessarily there
was a comment about how maybe we would
our vision was deploying it with Nat.
I'm not sure.
Of that,
I don't know if Sean you want to add
anything more in terms of vision and
deploying agents with Nemo Claw.
Yes, yes.
So the if you think about this like stack,
there's open shell, which is this runtime.
There's the agent inside of it,
which could be perbez,
it could be open claw Nat.
It's kind of a layer that would sit in
between those two things.
And so even when you're using the open
shell runtime, you still might want to be,
you know,
sending telemetry out to Phoenix so you
can see the traces.
You still might be able to run a your
offline eval of your agent to see like
how is it going to answer certain
questions.
Does it do that every single time in the
same way? Have we created regressions?
So all of these things that Nemo Agent
Toolkit does.
Continue to exist, and in fact,
one of the things that we're working
towards is having the Nima Cloud
Blueprint add to these agent harnesses
the hooks that Nat needs to.
To be able to like do that observability
and telemetry.
So so that's all in progress and that's
partly why at GTC you might have seen the
slides refer to this NVIDIA Agent toolkit.
Which is an umbrella that includes.
Open Shell Nemo Claw and Nemo Agent
Toolkit. I realize that's kind of bad.
Like that we had a Nemo Agent Toolkit,
NVIDIA Agent Toolkit. Yep,
that's that's not great,
but that is where where we're at.
I guess worth throwing up the the quick
slide of NVIDIA Agent Toolkit to show.
The idea,
at least this was the general idea.
This is also on high spot GPU team,
so if you want to find it, you can.
The idea is that you would have any agent,
right?
Any agent harness right can be deployed
with an open shell and have access to all
these things,
and that's what provides with the NVIDIA
Agent toolkit, right?
The image toolkit is also in there as
well,
right to allow you to build agents in a
framework agnostic way, right?
So I have previously deployed a, you know,
agent that I have built myself right
through.
The imaging toolkit deploy that in open
shell as part of the nvidia agent toolkit.
So I know the naming is a little
complicated,
but that is sort of the the test of it.
I know we have some other time.
Any any questions anybody want to ask?
Is the timeline in May?
My understanding is then after that we
would be able to run Nemoclaw on our
corporate network.
Yes, that's a real,
that's a really good question.
For.
So right now we are working through.
Enabling ingredients to use Nemoclaw
through Omnistation.
The same way that if you're like a Codex
or cloud power user with the auto run
stuff,
you can do that today on Omnistation.
So,
so we're working on on adding Nemoclaw as
a a third option there. It will probably.
I don't know if we have line of sight
towards having Nemoclaw run just like
locally on your laptop because you you
can think of Nemoclaw as.
As essentially auto run,
right it it it's giving the agent the
same autonomy as Codex and cloud in the
yellow or or auto run mode and so today
it has said you can do that on an Omni
station.
But not your on your directly on your
corporate device.
Now that Omni station will have access to
internal and external stuff,
so the so the same way you can have.
Claude, you know,
talk to our internal GitLab,
talk to systems that are on VPN over MCP
and that'll be available through through
Vigo Claude as well.
And that should happen, yes,
sometime in May.
I I I will. I keep forgetting.
It's already almost May,
Yes, I think it's the end of May. Yes,
I think end of May is the target.
but sometime in May is the the target.
Yes,
it's probably probably more copy text
related than.
OK, but for example,
if we set up an internal network or like
a network that is separated from our own
network,
like putting it on a private network on a
spark that is separated from all other
devices.
Then we shouldn't have any issues.
You just have to know how to set up the
You.
networking.
If you wanted to like do it today, yes,
running it on a spark that is not on VPN
is a great option if you have a spark.
The other option is Brev. You can run.
There's a Brev launchable that already
has like all the stuff installed.
Or you can start with like a vanilla Brev
VM and you run the installer to see like
what the client and user experience would
be.
Nebo Cloud doesn't necessarily need a GPU,
so you can even use like a Brev CPU
instance and those are super cheap.
Mhm.
To to get started.
And then for example,
I've been running trying to run mine but
I keep running and this might be it.
Maybe I shouldn't be saying this to like
out loud to everybody cause it's taking
time.
But I have been running into like broken
pipe issues and after looking at like the
troubleshooting guide I haven't found a
solution.
Do you have a recommendation or best
place to go to if we do run into problems?
Yes, I just threw it in the chat,
but that a new O'clock Community Slack
Yep.
channel is is the place to go.
Thank you.
Yes, definitely, definitely there.
appreciate your presentation.
It was quite good. Thank you.
There was a question around an example
repo or deployment of Openclaw wrapped by
Nat inside of Open Shell.
I don't think we necessarily have an
example of it wrapped by an e-mail Agent
Toolkit,
but we do have examples of an e-mail
Agent Toolkit.
Agent inside of open shell,
which I'm happy to point you towards.
It said we have the like hot off the
press is this.
Nexus Flow or whatever we're calling it,
Nemo Flow Nexus. So there,
Is it Nima flow?
not to maybe spill the the beams on
another tech transfer,
but Nemo Agent Toolkit.
But.
Is a is a library.
The team has created another library
which had the code name Nexus and maybe
the public name Nemoflow,
but that is that library is what we're
using to.
Bake into the Hermes and open claw images
to give you that observability that then
all the Nemo libraries can can use and
you can do great things with so so that
should be available.
I drop you text as well.
I.
Question. A question.
The chat was around for local models.
Anybody.
Anyone using anything besides old llama
pros, cons, reasoning?
Yes, the so the Nemo, yes,
the Nemo claw on board will pick up olama.
There's several other options out there.
It also there's experimental flags for to
pick up a VLM if you're if you're running
Ja.
that as well.
I I would say those are kind of the two
front runners that that I've used
personally.
Ja.
Agreed.
I think of course it is open source.
So if you know if you need or if you want
to contribute,
you know you want to add something like
LM Studio,
which is what Anthony put down there like.
I think they welcome it as far as I
understand.
The installer also had like when you're
running that nemoclaw on board.
One of the options is you just enter your
own base model URL.
So so if you for example you run LM
Studio to stand up a model in the
nemoclaw on board.
Wizard,
you can just say like it's at local host
8090 slash V1 and that'll be fine too.
Good question.
Is it easy to install Nimoclaw inside an
existing Open Shell environment?
If you have Open Shell already installed,
the Nimoclaw on board or will recognize
that and reuse the existing gateway.
So, so yes,
another question we didn't cover those.
I came up a lot when we first released
Nemo Claw and it is maybe a little less
relevant now is if you already have open
claw,
can you onboard it to Nemo Claw and there
was at first some.
Commands and tools to to help do that
migration.
What we've seen in practice is that it's
very tricky to get right and So what we
recommend instead is run democla fresh
and then there's a command to install any
skills.
That your Openclaw agent might have
developed over time and so rather than
trying to literally migrate Openclaw into
Nemoclaw,
the process is you start a fresh Nemoclaw
instance inside the sandbox and then pull
in those.
Skills and then kind of shut down the the
old one.
Yep.
So I ran into a odd problem and maybe
it's just for me not being familiar with
a llama cause of my first time using it
and stuff that I got in, I got everything,
I went through a bunch of reinstalls and
getting everything working and when I
finally was really close and I could
actually talk to it.
Talk through new Nemo,
Clio and Clash Shell. I was getting.
I would say hello and I would get like 12
pages of crazy hallucination stuff and
It.
eventually I found in some log file I was
tailing that it looked like Olama
defaulted to accepting like 40 or 4096
tokens,
but for whatever reason when I would just
say.
Say hello,
Open Shell or Neemuclire or however you
want to put it,
was sending to a llama like 12,
000 as opposed to its limit of 4000.
I bumped it up to 16,
000 on a llama and then it worked just
fine and I'm just playing around with the
GTX 3070 or RTX 3070 and stuff,
so it's not like it's anything big,
huge or awesome.
But I'm just, you know,
learning and I thought that was kind of
odd that I I don't know why Open Shell or
Nemocla would send 12,
000 tokens just when I say hello,
you know, now it says, well,
what would you like to help with?
But at first it was like pages and pages
of hallucination.
Does that sound normal?
So the.
One of the like key things,
whether you're using Ollama or VLM or
whatever,
for those inference endpoints to work
well with all these different agent
harnesses,
you have to be sure that like the correct
reasoning parser.
Is set up the correct tool calling parser
is set up and I it's configured to have
those long context windows.
Otherwise the agent harnesses all kind of
have different behaviors for how they set
up the.
Chat completions client and make the
request.
No.
And if the request is not compatible with
the inference endpoint,
things get wonky very quickly.
Ha.
Well, thank you.
I'm glad you got it. Got it to work.
Yes.
Yep, same.
I haven't done much with the yet,
but that's the next step.
No doubt.
Yes.
All right. Well,
I think if there's no other.
Questions we can give you guys a couple
of couple minutes back.
Thank you everybody for joining.
I will go ahead and send out the
recording at the end of end of the day
probably. I know Grayson,
you had posted a note about to submit
feedback. Do you want to mention that?
I I was thank you.
I was just about to say last thing is is
this was a great session.
If you all wouldn't mind in the chat I
put a link to a very quick survey just to
help provide feedback so that we can make
sure these sessions are always as useful
as possible for you guys.
All right. Thank you.
All righty. Thank you so much everybody.
Really appreciate you all's time and I
would look forward to seeing what you all
do with it.
Thanks everyone.
Thanks folks.
Thanks.